I'm gonna go to Eric from Cancun and I'm
doing this with significant trepidation
it's been a while since we heard from
Eric from Cancun Eric welcome what do
you have for me today
Eric from Cancun you were on the air
welcome
and absolutely last opportunity for Eric
from Cancun who I know has an agenda
every time he speaks to me but we can't
hear him he's not speaking
hello hello David Eric welcome welcome
welcome
amigo
I'm sorry my mic wasn't working I should
say right now I
because it seems I've seen the comments
of our calls and any are asking if I
could be a regular and
that if we can make a phone call I can
give you the whole cake instead of just
crumbs slices and pieces of my mind
um what do you say you know Eric I don't
know that my mind can handle more ideas
than what I get from you in the short
Snippets I don't know that I could even
I would be in recovery mode constantly
from your high level ideas
um
okay
um and in that case I'm just gonna ask
you
um is your child a boy or a girl
is my YouTube channel a boy or a girl is
that your question
now in is your do you have a daughter or
a son oh oh sorry I thought you were
asking me the gender of my my channel my
child no uh
um
um I'm very happy for you
Eric I that means a lot to me I
appreciate that
do you have any parenting tips
um
do the Himalayan style of parenting I
can explain it first you get a treat in
like a print like a princess you're
gonna give it anything you want to have
the best life from zero to five years
old okay from five to ten years old you
gotta beam to get with her like a worker
so you don't spoil her because if you
spoil her then she will learn how to
manipulate you and others
right and you're gonna give them
responsibilities so she knows where the
boundaries
right all right the Himalayan style of
parenting that's very interesting Eric
then from
10 to 15 you get with her more like an
adult that you're gonna let her Express
herself and have your own ideas but
don't criticize this too much because
then she will not want to tell you
anything because she will feel that you
would not listen to her right and then
from 15 to 20 to up you get your current
as an equal then you are in the same
level do you completely
I understand perfectly and Eric just by
the way is it okay that I'm feeding a
two-month-old pizza is that is that
allowed in the Himalayan style of
parenting
um
um I haven't seen it but even outside of
that I don't think so maybe around 40
years old okay very good no pizza until
age four Eric muchisi Mah gracias I
really appreciate your call today
I hope you can reconsider it someday all
right thank you very much there is Eric
from Cancun
absolutely shot out of a cannon I
genuinely thought he asked me the gender
of my YouTube channel I mean gender is
so big these days I was like I don't
know maybe that's a thing my channel has
a gender